I want a wee Judah eyes Catholicism in
many parts the Protestant movement
there's it there's a desire to deed you
two eyes the operation catholicism lifts
it up it doesn't want to leave it behind
christ is the yes to all the problems
has made israel here we are on the
sunday special with bishop Robert Barron
author of arguing religion we're gonna
get to all things Catholic Church
related to religion related life after
life God death it'll be some deep stuff
but first let's talk about the fact
you're gonna plotz so life insurance is
deeply unfun to talk about because most
people don't like to think about dying
they definitely don't like thinking
about insurance because these are two
topics no one likes death and insurance
but actually having life insurance feels
great
getting that peace of mind doesn't need
to be complicated policy genius is an
easy way to get life insurance in
minutes you can compare quotes from top
insurers to find the coverage you need
at a price you can afford from there you
can apply online if the unbiased
advisors that policy genius will handle
all the red tape leaving you free to do
the things you actually enjoy like
philosophical discussions about religion
in the afterlife policy genius doesn't
just make life insurance easy whether
you're shopping for disability insurance
to protect your income or homeowners
insurance or auto insurance they can
help you get covered fast if you've been
intimidated or frustrated by insurance
in the past give policy genius a try
just go to policy genius calm right now
get your quote and apply in minutes you
can do the whole thing on your phone
right now this instant policy genius
it's the easy way to compare and buy
life insurance be a responsible human
don't leave your family bereft so they
can't pay for your coffin if to bury you
in a pauper's grave go check out policy
genius right now the easy way to compare
and buy life insurance well Bishop Baron
thank you so much for joining the
program I really appreciate it my
pleasure to be with you I have to say
that I've gotten an enormous number of
requests for you to come on the show
particularly in the aftermath of an
interview we did a couple of weeks ago
with Pastor John MacArthur and I'll have
some questions about differences between
Catholic and Protestant theology in just
a minute but let's start off with with a
personal question so how did you decide
to enter the priesthood was this
something where as a child you thought
this is what I'm gonna be doing not
really when I was a little kid I came
you know a Catholic family went to Mass
on Sunday but I wasn't all that
interested in religion I wanted to be a
baseball player so I was a Cub fan from
Chicago I wanted to be a shortstop for
the Cubs till I was about 14 and when I
was 14
I'm in highschool religion class and one
of the professor's taught us one of
thomas aquinas arguments for God's
existence and I'm sure no other kid in
the room was the least bit affected by
it but for some reason it affected me
I went home went to the library back in
the day when she went to libraries and
got books out and I got Mortimer Adler's
you know the great book series and I
found the one on Thomas Aquinas and then
read that section understanding almost
none of it but it started me honestly on
a path I never left it just sort of set
my mind on fire and the priesthood came
you know further down the pike but it
started then when I was 14 and baseball
is still an interest of mine but I
realized I was going down a different
path one well that's really fascinating
because when you speak with a lot of
religious leaders they tend to come from
the perspective that they got into
religion specifically through the Bible
and Aquinas is proofs of God's existence
are really non biblical in nature I mean
they're natural law based more than
anything else I mean this is really what
you argue in your book arguing religion
is that that's where people should start
maybe can discuss a little bit what's
your favorite to mystic proof of God's
existence and why you think it's
convincing the one I heard probably as a
kid was the proof emotions for the first
argument recliners but the one I develop
in the book actually is not specifically
Aquinas it's more of an amalgam of his
three I would call it the argument from
contingency namely the world that we
experience as a contingent world it's
non self explanatory so it's it exists
but not necessarily it exists through an
amalgam of causes they themselves are
non self explanatory so we have to go
further in our quest for the sufficient
explanation that can't go on
indefinitely we have to come finally to
some principle some reality which
fulfills the conditions of everything
else but itself does not have any
conditions to be filled the the octaves
purest Aquinas calls the right pure act
of pure energy that which exists through
itself so in various ways proofs one two
and three and Aquinas are versions of
that argument and I think most people
intuitively sense it so you know there's
this massive consensus gentium across
the ages that God exists I mean the vast
majority people across human history of
Hell that God exists now they can't
formulate arguments in a strict
a philosophical way but they they sense
it seems to me they sense the even
essence of this world and therefore the
the need for an ultimate ground you know
so I think that proof makes explicit
what a lot of people implicitly Intuit
about the reality of God in your book
you talk a little bit about the the
probably largest kind of pushback to
that specific argument which is the idea
of sort of base matter that there is no
God that the very root the only real
cause is just the matter itself well how
do you respond of the Bertrand Russell
base back sorry yeah we know I want
people to say look I buy the argument
there's got to be some sort of you know
final ground for the existence of things
or some ultimate cause the problem is
what the proof uncovers is not just a
first cause in a long series and
uncovers that which is properly
unconditioned in its reality so that
which exists entirely through the power
of its own essence that means something
which by its very nature is unlimited in
being because there's no condition
that's set for it when you say matter
you're saying being at the opposite end
of that spectrum manner is entirely of
malleable it's entirely full of
potentiality it's the opposite of okto
spears or the uncondition so the one
thing this reality can't be is material
which is why people like Aquinas many
others would say the first mover the
uncaused cause is not a body of any kind
not material so it's a it's a facile
answer but it can't correspond to what
that proof actually uncovers the
unconditioned reality so you talked a
lot about in your book arguing religion
about skepticism and and why you think
that skepticism is is unwarranted
in many cases maybe you can talk about
the limits of skepticism because we
think that all of Western civilization
or at least the in low post
enlightenment civilization is built on
the idea of being skeptical but when it
comes to religion obviously skepticism
has been used to tear down religion yeah
I mean its modern form and the core I
picked to Agustin and his battle against
what he called the academics you know
see followers soon Agustin says if I
make a mistake I am Day cards coach Ito
ergo assume is just a riff on that I
mean he learned it from Augusta if I'm
making a mistake about absolutely
everything at least I know I am so
agustin used that to refute a radical
skepticism anyone that engages in
rational discourse is not a radical
skeptic I mean anyone that engages in
what we're doing now some kind of
conversation is appealing implicitly or
explicitly to some objective standard of
truth of moral goodness you know so a
complete radical skepticism is just
incoherent it can be used as a tool you
know as a kind of provisional tool to
move the mind along but you can't accept
as a worldview a radical skepticism it's
more post modernity I think that moves
in that direction of a you know kind of
dismantling of all the epistemic and
moral systems you can't finally do that
and have something like a rational
discourse okay so when it comes to
skepticism you talk again in the book
about skepticism and your chief response
to people who are skeptical about
religion is that there are perfectly
rational reasons to believe particularly
in God and you use the two mystic proofs
as we were discussing which are non
revelatory in nature they're their basic
ration trying to reason from the nature
of the world to what that world is about
but it seems to me that most of the
people who are skeptical of religion are
not actually skeptical of God per se
they actually like the idea of God in
essence how do you get from that to the
Bible how'd you get from that to
Revelation which obviously makes a lot
more stringent claims that that have to
be tried against reason and very often
are found wanting the miraculous in many
cases well I'll say a couple things I
mean one is that Aquinas is basing that
approach on the Bible in a way I mean
because the the heavens proclaim the
glory of God the Bible says or Paul you
know from the visible things of this
world we can move to the invisible
things of God so within the Bible itself
there's a kind of warrant for what we
call natural theology or philosophical
approved but yeah I'd say this
acquaintance refers to his famous
arguments as a type of mondo Dook CEO
Latin for leading by the hand the way
you take a little child that come on let
me let me help you let me show you you
know how to walk
so that philosophical arguments can lead
someone who let's say is totally outside
the realm of the religious to the point
where they might be able to accept
what's given in Revelation to accept the
revelation of the Bible might be too
much for someone especially today who's
completely outside the ambit of
but the arguments might awaken the mind
sufficiently or give a sufficient
warrant to say yeah I'll take a look at
the Bible that's what I mean I use the
example of getting to know a person
right so I meeting you for the first
time today but I did you know a fair
amount of looking into your background
I've seen videos you've done etc I came
my own conclusions about you know
watching you in action and reading about
you
now I'm meeting you for the first time
I'm learning more about you on my own
terms
so I'm using my mind to learn different
things about you I mean let's say over
many years then we became friends and I
came to know you more and more at a
certain point you would tell me
something about yourself if our
friendship deepened sufficiently that I
would never have guessed or known
independently of that
at which point I'd have to make an act
of faith I'd have to say yeah I believe
that I can't prove it I can't know it
directly now it's it's consistent with
everything else I've learned about you
it's not some egregious claim right but
finally I've got to say yeah I believe
him I've come to trust him I think
that's the analogy for reason in
relation to faith when it comes to God
you can discover an awful lot of things
through the mind if by looking at the
world and reasoning about it and lots of
our great thinkers have done that that
can lead me into the forecourt of the
temple if you want you know but at a
certain point our great tradition claims
that God speaks we don't mean that you
know literally but I mean that God has
revealed something about his own heart
that we couldn't have guessed on the
basis of reason I have to say okay I
believe or not I have to say I accept
that or not but reason can predispose me
to that point of acceptance that's how
the Catholic Church sort of does it the
play of faith and reason
moving into the forecourt of the
Gentiles is not a bad place to be
because it predisposes you to the point
of of the act of faith you know but you
need more than reason I mean
philosophical reason would not be
sufficient for someone seeking real
communion with God so why not why I mean
this is the argument obviously the
decline
asks about he says why in addition to
natural laws you actually need a Bible
why do you need revelation so what's the
answer to that for you why is it that we
can't just given all of the premises of
a new universe created by an intelligent
being with with a plan and with kindness
and goodness why do we need a set of
Commandments why do we need or in the in
the Christian view Savior to come down
and in terms the nature of the world
itself well answer the first question
you know Aquinas and our tradition would
tend to say the the Ten Commandments
correspond roughly to the first
principles of the natural law and so in
Manatee says the salmon are yeah and so
in a way that's true there's a there's a
overlap between the two see I would just
now speak as a Christian and say there's
no way on the basis of philosophical
arguments that I can ever know that God
loves me to the point of giving his own
self as a gift to me that God died that
I might come into union with him and
there's no way I could learn that
through philosophical argumentation that
that God is love I mean the great
Central Christian claim which is a
Trinitarian claim right if God is love
there's lover beloved and shared love
within the very nature of God how do we
know that well the first Christians knew
it from the cross of Jesus you know that
God so loved the world he sent His only
Son into our disfunction drawing now the
son back to the Father in the Holy
Spirit to save us I can't guess it there
there's no argument for that it's
congruent with the God who's the
unconditioned act of being itself and
all of that there's no way I would have
guessed at that I couldn't come to that
on my own that was revealed and then
from the depth of my heart I say yes to
that I accept that revelation is true
and the same is true I think within
Judaism as well you know but that's the
play when we faith in reason oh yeah
I've never been at home I love
Kierkegaard but I've never been at home
with the leap of faith thing because
especially the waves used today as
though it's simply this wild leap into
the dark it's not that it's you know
we've been brought to a certain point by
our minds but then from that perspective
from that point we're able to make this
act of loving acceptance more easily you
know
but no we can't reduce it to reason or
you'd never guess that that god is love
to the point of death I mean and I think
there are serious questions if you asked
about whether reason alone can bring you
to the point of even beyond the Ten
Commandments how far reason can get you
because there are limitations to the
moral societies that have been created
by human beings and if it really true
that we could create a moral society
under any circumstances simply by the
act of reason alone human beings all
over the world have been capable of
reason and yet the the goodness that
we've seen in terms of Rights and and
prosperity all of this only arises in
the context of one civilization with one
specific history limits quiz a very
interesting thing I'm thinking too
though of in the Christian context of
the love of one's enemies that's not an
entirely rational principle I mean
that's something that's we'd say the
result of a supernatural grace they seem
can we love your enemy that you will the
good of your enemy for your enemy's sake
so not that we're down to your benefit
but you love that's again Aquinas to
will the good of the other as other even
your enemy that's not a rational thing
to do you won't find that in Aristotle
you won't find that in the great for in
condemn system for example but you find
at the heart of the gospel because it's
predicated upon grace that the love of
God that goes all the way to the limits
of God forsaken us that God loves us his
enemies for our own sake if we're
capable of that it's because of grace
operating in us not justice of our own
music or our own you know will to excel
that's the that's the result of a pure
gift you know so all of that belongs to
the properly theological dimension of
Christian thought and behavior so the
second I ask you some very awkward
questions about differences between our
two religion and how we live together in
peace and harmony but first let's talk
about how you're gonna sleep better so I
know you are riveted by this
conversation as am i but at some point
tonight you're gonna have to go to sleep
and when you do the question is why
would you buy a generic mattress built
for somebody else
helix sleep has built a sleep quiz that
takes two minutes to complete they use
the answers to match your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress whether you're a side sleeper
or a hot sleeper with you like a plush
or for a bed with helix there's no more
guessing and no more
confusion just go to helix sleep calm /
bed and guests because I have a guest
take their two minutes sleep quiz they
will match you to a mattress that will
give you the best sleep of your life
my wife and I have a helix sleep
mattress it is fantastic we went onto
the helix sleep website we did the two
minutes sleep quiz it came in the mail
we unwrapped it and inflated in front of
us
we toss it on the bed frame we were good
to go it's so comfortable I got one for
my sister for her wedding as well for
couples helix can even split that
mattress down the middle providing
individual support needs and feel
preferences for each side they also have
a 10 year warranty you get to try it out
for a hundred nights risk-free so what
exactly are you waiting for
right now helix is offering up to 125
bucks off all mattress orders again up
to 145 bucks off at helix sleep calm /of
been guests that is helix sleep calm /
been guests for 125 bucks off your
mattress order helix sleep calm / been
guest ok so I promised awkward questions
and so there she'll be so let's start
with the most awkward of the awkward
questions I don't really care about this
question particularly much when I get
this question a lot which is you know as
a Jew how does it feel that there are
other religions that don't think you're
getting into heaven so let me ask you
what's the Catholic view on who gets
into heaven and who doesn't I feel like
I lead a pretty good life a very
religiously based life in which I try to
keep not just the 10 commandments but a
solid 603 other Commandments as well and
I spend an awful lot of my time
promulgating what I would consider be
judeo-christian virtues particularly in
Western societies so what's the Catholic
view of me am I basically screwed here
no the Catholic view would go back to
the Second Vatican Council says it very
clearly I mean Christ is the privileged
route to salvation my God so loved the
world he gave His only Son that we might
find eternal life so that's the
privilege relat however vatican ii
clearly teaches that someone outside the
explicit christian faith can be saved
now they're saved through the grace of
christ indirectly received so I mean the
grace is coming from Christ but it might
be received according to your of
conscience so if you're following your
conscience sincerely or in your case
you're following the commandments of the
law sincerely yeah you can be saved
now that doesn't conduce to a complete
relativism I mean we still would say the
privileged route and and the the route
that God has offered to humanity is the
route of his son but no you can be saved
even Vatican 2 says an atheist of
goodwill can be saved because in
following his conscience if he does John
Henry Newman said the conscience is the
average
Vicar of Christ in the soul it's very
interesting characterization that it is
in fact the voice of Christ if he's the
law Gauss made flesh right
he's the divine mind or reason made
flesh that when I follow my conscience
I'm following him whether I know it
explicitly or not so even the Atheist
vatika to teachers of good will can be
saved
so is Catholicism act based or faith
based because this has been sort of the
traditional distinction between Judaism
for example in Christianity is Judaism
is a very acts based religion where it's
all about what you do in this life and
that earns you points in heaven and then
there's the faith-based religions that
are more based on you believe in the
truth way in the life and now you're in
where where does Catholicism actually
stand or is that division two star no I
would say it's love based God is love
God so loved the world he sounds only
Son we're being drawn into the Divine
Love now do we have to accept that love
as an act of faith
of course right so so God makes this
great offer in Christ is it accepted in
faith yeah acquaintances faith is the is
the door of the spiritual life without
faith you can't get into the spiritual
life that means a trust in the Divine
Love now having made that great
fundamental act are you now called upon
to be fully engaged mind will passion
body everything in response to that love
a love awakening love in you yes so we'd
use the language of cooperation with
grace and that grace comes first
accepted in faith Luther was right to
that extent if Luther had said gratia
Prima we'd be fine grace first is true
at any time you're relating to God if
you're saying well I'm gonna do it I am
on my way to climb the holy mountain
well then you're on the wrong path just
by definition so of course it begins
with grace but then God who's not
competitive with us he he wants us fully
alive and so God invites us now to
respond body and soul everything we've
got in love to the love that he's
offered us so I put it that way it's
grace and then cooperation with grace
which manifests itself in a life of love
and that's what what salvation
consistent see one thing to then think
of this way what gets me to heaven well
what
is heaven you know Paul says you know
the three things that last faith hope
and love but the greatest of these is
love because in heaven faith fades away
I don't need faith anymore I'm seeing
and heaven hope fades away who needs to
hope you got it but love indoors because
love is what heaven is so you say well I
don't care my love it's just a phase
pure faith well what are you gonna do
all day in heaven well what will heaven
that's what heaven is is that is the act
of love so it begins here below as we
cooperate with grace I'd say that's the
the Catholic way of looking at it so
well how do you square that with the
sort of modern perception of what love
is so so many people in Western society
believe the love is essentially
tolerance whatever my friend was to do
I'm on their side I'm with them I have
to boost their self-esteem and you know
that's the ultimate love if it if I were
to if I were to signal my my discontent
with their behavior or to say that they
were acting morally or try to correct
them that this would actually be acting
contrary to love you you take a pretty
strong view on the over application of
tolerance in your book so yeah I mean
tolerance is the great modern virtue so
you might say that you know diversity is
what we accept and therefore tolerance
is the great virtue but see tolerance
would not really be a Christian virtue
love is the virtue now it can include
what we mean by by tolerance but the
trouble is this see love means willing
the good of the other as other that
might take the form as it does for
example I'm a great prophets of calling
somebody out and saying look what you're
doing is repugnant to God's will that's
willing you're good that's not coming
down hard on you that's willing what's
best for you so that tough love
sure that's a face of love you know so
if you prioritize tolerance you're
you're marginalizing what belongs at the
very heart of the matter which is the
willing of the good of the other that's
the virtue we want do you think that
religion mainline religion whether a
Catholic Protestants or Jewish is having
trouble specifically because people are
mistaking one for the other I can see it
in my Jewish community right I can see
that the Orthodox are growing we
continue to grow as a sect of Judaism
and as I would say the most authentic
sect of Judaism that actually cares
about the words of the Torah it's it's
growing kids tend to stay involved but
other sects of Judaism tend to fade away
over time but that's not stopping the
Jewish
community from thinking okay the way I'm
gonna get these kids who are
disenchanted back into the synagogue's
is with guitar and pizza and parties we
went down that road in the Catholic
Church I grew up in that time after
vatican ii you know and it rather
massively didn't work no I think it's
the great spiritual masters they all
know this I mean Dostoevsky famously
saying you know real love is a harsh and
dreadful thing so real love is not this
sort of bland you know namby-pamby
anything goes you know I'm okay you're
okay on the contrary
real love wants the good of the other
and so it makes demands and it upsets
people very often that the real thing so
it's not sentimental we you know hyper
sentimentalized a lot of religious
language and that's caused huge problems
there's something kind of spare and
bracing about the at Aquinas language of
willing the good of the other and that
can take a softer form if you want and
can take a harder form depending on the
circumstances but the focus is always on
the other as other it's like when the
Lord says you know to love your enemies
as I was saying that's the great test of
love because if it's your enemy this is
not someone's gonna paint you back so if
I'm kind to you that you might be kind
to me
well that's not love right that's an
indirect egotism I I will give you a
party that you might give me a party in
return that's why in the Sermon on the
Mount Jesus says exactly that don't give
a party for those who can repay you
right don't loan to those who can pay
you back with interest that's not the
point the point is to is to be good to
those that can't return the favor that's
tough stuff both for you and often for
the other person and right that modern
tolerance is kind of a vague simulacrum
above I want to ask you some some basic
kind of Catholic doctrinal questions
because I think we in the general public
laurent catholic have some basic views
about catholicism that are likely wrong
but well accepted so papal infallibility
can you just define that how far does
the Pope's infallibility go do I have to
take everything if I'm a Catholic that
he says it at face value is some of it
political interpretation what is you
know the the Vicar of Christ and what is
just him saying things
yeah well it's a it's very narrowly
defined that's the important thing with
in Catholic ecclesiology we say the
theology of the church when the Pope
speak
we say ex cathedra from the chair right
in the formal manner on matters of faith
and morals for the sake of the entire
church he's speaking infallible it's
happened precisely
twice and since the thing was was
declared formally so this is a very very
rare thing we did we speak about the
infallibility of the ordinary
Magisterium now that means the bishops
in union with the Pope teaching on a key
matter of faith and morals in general
consensus around the world we recognize
that as an infallibility of this
ordinary teaching of the church but the
Pope himself sent such rare occasion now
the Pope does deliver himself of formal
teachings like encyclicals which have to
be taken with tremendous seriousness but
might a Catholic you know quarrel here
and there was something in this cyclical
sure it's not an infallible statement
much less certain Prudential judgments
of a pope Pope might make a judgement a
Prudential determination about a policy
within the church or a political
judgment is one obliged to accept that
no I mean we we approach the Pope always
in an attitude of deep respect he's a
successor of Peter he's the Vicar of
Christ he's the guarantor of our unity
so the Pope is is always treated with
enormous respect but the infallibility
is a very very narrowly defined quality
so I think it's the danger is like
though the Pope's is gonna rain tomorrow
therefore it is gonna rain tomorrow no
no that's not Catholic teaching I mean
what what's Catholic teaching as far as
how doctrine develops so over the course
of centuries where's the limitations
because what we see in the Orthodox
Jewish community we're seeing this now
is in Orthodox Judaism we have this idea
of the oral law which is the
interpretation of the text of the Torah
and this continues over centuries and it
leaves open the possibility if you're
not careful of people straying from the
text so far that they are actually
contravening the text I assume that
you've had some similar problems in in
Catholicism itself as well so how does
that how is interpretation limited and
sort of Catholic doctrine yeah I go back
to John Henry Newman there who says that
ideas don't exist on on the pages of
books but in the play of lively Minds he
says you know so you and I talking right
now it's an example of an idea is is
developing it's unfolding so Newman says
the way you know that the seed goes into
the great
or my preferred one from Newman is the
way the river begins very small but then
it it deepens and broadens and takes in
all kinds of influences as it moves
through space and time and so like the
idea of the incarnation as as st. Peter
took it in as st. Paul articulated it
now as Chris system articulates it as
Jerome articulates it as Agustin and
Aquinas and so on
that's the river deepening and
broadening over space and time now to
your point because ideas develop they
can corrupt so it can be the case that
you've you've deviated from the
essential meaning of an idea that's
where the authority of a church comes in
so we're not just a debating society
that's a danger it's been across the
ages but especially today is to turn the
church into a debating society so let's
all just get together and we have this
open-ended conversation and we never
decide anything so the danger of
corruption there is extremely high so
the church through its bishops
and through the Pope ultimately it's
like an umpiring voice I made use the
baseball analogy the play is going on
there's there's a bang-bang play at
second base and the call was made right
you're out and people might dispute it
you know you're crazy you didn't see it
right but if we allow that to go on that
dispute the game just unravels right the
game ends so real baseball people like
umpires even though we know we Boo and
they kind of feel but a real baseball
person likes the umpire thank God thank
God the umpires there to say no look man
you're out okay I know you don't like it
but off the field and the game goes on
see and that's the right rhythm the game
of theology is this play of lively Minds
good theologians and people talking and
arguing and back and forth and the thing
developing but occasionally and if you
over umpire like over referee a
basketball game that wrecks the game to
right call on every little thing so
occasionally the church would intervene
to say nope that's not it that's too far
that's that's a unraveling of the idea
now play ball off you go so this raises
another question which is if the church
is the umpire the the critique that's
been made particularly by Protestants
pastor John MacArthur sat in the chair
that you're sitting in just a few weeks
ago and his argument was basically that
by the
18th century the church had become more
of an obstacle than a middleman more of
a continent less a conduit to to the
truth of the Bible and more of an
obstacle to people understanding the
truth of the Bible has there been a time
when you think the Catholic Church has
done that or is the Catholic Church
always served its purpose of being sort
of the middleman between God and the and
the normal Christian well I say couple
things one is the the principle ecclesia
semper reformed andhe right the church
must always be reformed that's a
Catholic principle it's an ancient
patristic principle so when Luther picks
that up is a great reformer
that's a Catholic principle of course
the church is always to be reformed the
church you know in its particular
expressions and the particular people
that play these these roles can you know
can go off beam sometimes however I
don't want the umpire off the field
because then the play is gonna unravel
and I would dare say you know I say with
great affection for all my Protestant
friends and for Protestantism
but the 30000 denominations of present
ISM is not a good reflection of Jesus
great prayer that they might be one one
of the guarantors of unity is precisely
this umpiring voice in the church I'd
further more say this that would you
pick up Hamlet and hand it to a kid and
say off you go just read it you'll be
fine you'll understand it no I mean we
we surround hamlet with this this
complex interpretive apparatus and a
tradition of reception and we we help
someone read that complex text through
that interpretive lens that's why I
think it's borderline irresponsible just
pick up the Bible to sense a you know
off you go read it when it comes to it
when it comes to the unity of the church
the an argument could be made and it has
been made by folks like Sam Harris for
example that the unity of the church is
what led to theocracy for hundreds of
years that basically between the fall of
the Roman Empire and the peace of
westphalia you have catholic dominance
across the continents of Europe and that
results in a certain level of
intellectual stagnation he would argue
it results in a hidebound attempt to
victimize people of other religions
how does Catholicism make room
for other religions in the absence of
Protestantism for example I mean is the
rise of Protestantism seen by
Catholicism is a bad thing in the sense
that it it does all the things that
you've talked about before or does it
provide room for the flourishing of more
than one type of religion and at a
certain level of diversity that's that's
good for the conversation yeah you're
raising a complex set of questions there
I mean to the degree that modernity as
we know it politically emerged out of
Protestantism which I think it did in
many ways many important ways the church
has found an awful lot of good within
modernity and and doesn't advocate now
certainly this kind of altar throwing
relationship sort of thing we don't
advocate you know taking over the
government of the church running
political affairs there's a legitimate
independence and legitimate integrity
you know to the political reality so I
mean the church wouldn't want that by
any means to that degree I think it
embraces very much the modern sense of
pluralism and a certain separation
between the church's preoccupation and
that of politics so I don't we have no
quarrel with that you know you go back
to history and say well it was done
differently a long time ago but I think
to that degree we'd embrace you know a
lot of those modern reforms because I
want to ask you in just a second about
contrasting various Pope's over the over
the past the course of my lifetime are
not that old so only three but I'll ask
you to compare and contrast in just a
second first let's talk about your
investing so Robin Hood is an investing
app it lets you buy and sell stocks ETFs
options kryptos all commission-free they
strive to make financial services work
for everybody not just for wealthy folks
it's a non intimidating way for stock
market newcomers to invest for the first
time with confidence it's simple and
intuitive bunch of folks at the office
use it it is clearly designed the data
are presented and easy to digest way
other brokerages charge up to ten bucks
for every trade so you lose maybe the
insider profit margin on a trade but
Robin Hood doesn't charge commission
fees you trade the stocks and you keep
all your profits
it's got easy-to-understand charts
market data you place a trade in just
four taps on your smartphone and the
Robin Hood web platform lets you view
stock collections like 100 most popular
in sectors like entertainment social
media and curated categories like female
CEOs analysts ratings of buy hold sell
for every stock learn how to invest as
you build your portfolio discover new
stocks and track favorite companies with
personalized news feeds
custom notifications for price movements
all sorts of great stuff Robin Hood
right now is giving listeners a free
style
like Apple Ford or Sprint to help build
your portfolio sign up right now at ben
shapiro dot Robinhood calm that's Ben
Shapiro dot Robin Hood calm it's a
fantastic app it'll help you learn to
trade better go check it out ben shapiro
dot robin hood calm so when last we left
our subject i was going to ask you about
the three Pope's of the last twenty five
years three years so Pope John Paul the
second Pope Benedict and Pope Francis no
as a Jew I get to criticize Pope Salva
much I want which is great for me but my
perception has been that Pope John Paul
the second obviously a historic figure
in many ways particularly in his
anti-communism Pope Benedict a
traditionalist one of the great
religious thinkers of our time and I've
been highly critical of Pope Francis
who's been perceived by the media as
much more progressive on politics much
more focused on issues like global
warming than for example abortion do you
think that that is a a mislabel of Pope
Francis's actual legacy or do you think
the media are doing a responsible job in
covering what exactly Pope Francis is
doing yeah I mean he's every Pope has a
specific emphasis I mean so John Paul
coming out of his great struggle with
communism and that massively influences
his social thinking Benedict I think
coming out of his European cultural
background and wanting very much to
realized Errol I would say that's maybe
key to him Francis coming out of his
Latin American specifically Argentinian
background and I think a certain
suspicion that probably of American
capitalism is in the Pope's
you know thinking in his intellectual
wheelhouse he's a prophetic type voice
so he's critical he does what the
prophets often do he criticizes what he
takes to be all these excesses within
the capitalist system he's not so much a
constructive thinker they're like what's
he proposing as as the way forward he's
you know in the sort of jeremiah mode I
think of putting his finger on excesses
now read John Paul two on the market
economy for example he's a great
advocate of it in Centesimus annus you
know he said the church advocates the
the market he prefers to call and then
rather than capitalism but very clearly
says a market circumscribed morally
circumscribed legally a market that is
not simply you know open to the free
play of
you know buying and selling etc so I
think Frances picks up on that side of
it maybe without the the balance you
found typically in a John Paul but
that's also typical of the profits they
tend to be a little over-the-top that's
how I read France well what do you think
of the critique that's been made by a
lot of folks that he is a devotee of
liberation theology because no I think
that's all that's all most domestically
false because at a certain point in his
development I mean he knew the
liberation theology movement and turned
against it it's more of a populism I
would say it was not the embrace of the
Marxist option he was very influenced by
a Frenchman called Gaston facade who was
a mid-century a French Jesuit sharply
critical of Marx and of Marxism and so I
think bergoglio consciously departs from
liberation theology ops were a different
path it's it's more of a populism
it's an embrace of popular piety it's an
embrace of of kind of the people I mean
the Marxist sense of the term but more
in this latin-american sense so I think
it's he's demonstrable not with
liberation theology well the media have
been obviously very Pro Pope Francis
yeah much more than they were obviously
with Benedict or with John Paul the
second for most of his life as he
approached his his death obviously
became much more Pro because this is
typical and how the media treat people
who they perceive to not agree with them
politically and yet the the the focus on
the Catholic Church more broadly beyond
Pope Francis by the media has been
almost entirely in the past couple of
decades on the number of sex scandals
what do you think is the best way for
the church to deal with sex scandals how
serious is the problem do you think that
the media are basically picking on the
church as opposed to other institutions
in society that had similar problems
well there's something true to that and
I'm always reluctant you know to lead as
I'm doing right now to lead with that
looking defensive but I think that's
certainly fair to say that this problem
is a universal human problem you can
find in almost every institution every
society I would say in God's providence
that it was brought to light so
dramatically in the church to force you
know to bring it to the world's
attention and it's part of what the
church is is bearing a legitimate
punishment I would say but for the sake
of the world that that what we've had to
wrestle with I think now is benefiting
other institutions but it is fair to say
that the problem is much wider than
Catholicism one stat that I think is
very interesting is this across the
board and across the decades you look at
the numbers and when they're presenting
kind of a raw form you see how you know
horrific and of course one act of child
sex abuse is a riveting but when you
look at the numbers they almost always
correspond roughly to the national
average of about four percent you look
at men across society roughly four
percent engage in this behavior that's
almost how it breaks down across the
board within the Catholic Church so in
that sense - it's unfair to say it's a
uniquely Catholic problem and having
said all that I think it is important
that it's being brought to light
precisely in that framework so that we
can bring healing to it and maybe deeper
instruction than to other institutions
as well
I don't think the media is picking on
the church in this measure that thank
God for the media you know that that
revealed the thing when the church to be
frank was not as willing or able to deal
with it thank God in a way for them for
the Boston Globe that brought this thing
to light so I I don't really quarrel
with that you know I think just as in
the Old Testament God using Cyrus I mean
God can use even enemies of Israel to to
affect Israel in a positive way did God
use enemies of the church in a way to to
help the church yeah I think so
well what do you make of the schism that
seems to have been breaking out inside
the Catholic Church at the upper
echelons over the handling of the sex
abuse crisis by the by the Vatican
for example I'm very hopeful the
February meeting coming up when the Pope
is gathering the presidents of all the
bishops conferences from around the
world I'm very hopeful that we'll make
some important moves I'll confess to be
disappointed you know as a member of the
Bishops Conference last November we
gathered and we wanted very much to vote
on some very specific measures protocols
that would address this issue and the
Vatican asked us to pause they didn't
say you know it's over don't do it they
said pause could you wait till February
I'll confess to being disappointed along
with most of my colleagues anything
might there be good reasons for that
yeah they didn't give us the reasons
why weird applause it could be the
Vatican wants a a singular you know
universal protocol didn't want us
operating independently there might be
some canonical considerations that what
we're proposing might have been out of
step with canon law that's why I'm
hopeful the February meeting will take
some very specific steps so I always
think of sysm I think there's there
everybody in the church wants to address
this thing at the level of protocols and
the level of deeper conversion we're
debating I think how best to do the
first one what what do you make of the
critique that comes up every time one of
these sex abuse cases comes up where
folks basically suggest that the problem
is chastity within the priesthood that
we should allow priests to get marry you
know use all my celibacy television's
chastity is good right I mean that
create its lack of fidelity its lack of
following of biblical sexual ethics that
is the fundamental problem it's not
celibacy and that's demonstrable the
case that's been shown across the
decades that celibacy is not the cause
of this problem it's you know at the
moral level it's a deep infidelity
it's it's a failure to live up to our
own teaching so our our teaching is
eminently clear on the score you know so
it's priest sadly tragically not living
up to the teaching of the church but I
certainly wouldn't blame it on celibate
priesthood you know the overwhelming
majority of child sex offenders are not
syllabus so I wouldn't correlate it to
celibacy and to get into even more
controversial territory obviously the
church has come under significant fire
for its perspective on homosexuality I
always find this puzzling since this is
legitimately not changed neither Judaica
or Christian theology for a solid
several millennia right at this point
but nonetheless it is raised every
single time and it seems to be raised
every time there's a scandal inside the
church where folks suggest that many in
the hierarchy of the church itself
suggest that there a disproportionate
number of homosexual priests in
circulation and that this is a problem
for the for the celibacy inside the
church what do you make of that critique
yeah I mean I there's never been really
good or definitive Studies on that issue
of number of homosexuals in the
priesthood I mean it'd be very hard to
determine that as to
civil crowns that the majority of cases
of the sexual misconduct have been
male-on-male sexual violence that's true
and I think that's certainly worth
looking at to your first point yes
the consensus gents iam across millennia
across the cultures has been you know
that sex belongs within marriage between
a man and a woman who are faithful to
each other and open to life I mean that
was the standard consensus that most
human beings tend to fall away from it
ideal sure I mean that's always been the
case but that that's the ideal almost
everybody up until really a handful of
years ago accepted that which is why it
is it is rather an act of hubris you
know to say like how in the world could
you hold this I mean everyone has held
this view and there are good reasons
grounded in the natural law I'd say you
know for that perspective that people
fall away from it sure they always have
but even people within the church are
falling away from it tragically yeah but
that shouldn't compel us to change the
teaching so what exactly is the the
church holding on abortion as well so
obviously abortions another area where
the Catholic Church has come under
significant fire again this has always
been Catholic Church policy but it does
not matter the media every time the Pope
expresses that he's pro-life seem to
react with shock and horror as though
something new has happened yeah and
that's a good point that Pope Francis
has been very strong on the pro-life
issue the direct the direct taking of
innocent life is prohibited I mean
that's it's a fundamental I would say
the fundamental principle the natural
law all the other principles are derived
from it the direct killing of the
innocent is always prohibited it's
intrinsically evil to use our language
intrinsic chamalla in other words no
motive or circumstance could ever
obviate the truth of that if that goes
everything goes it seems to me now you
know I came of age at a time in the
Catholic Church when when the
proportional astir proach was very
popular in fact was being taught to a
lot of us namely that well you know
there things aren't intrinsically evil
it's you look at the you know the good
and bad consequences of an act and you
kind of add them up and if there's a
proportion between them you know then
make up your mind
the troubleman head is at the end of the
day I mean anything can be justified and
if you can justify the
killing the innocent it seems to be the
whole moral program falls apart and that
it's why the church has taken such a
strong stance against abortion because
it's such a clear instance of the
violation of that principle so no no we
we stand with it we have and we will so
to sort of finish up the hot-button
political section of this particular
interview I would be a risk I didn't ask
about the the Catholic Church's decision
to recognize the Catholic Church in
China which is obviously being cracked
down on in severe fashion and and
basically run in many ways by the
Chinese government do you think that's a
good decision or a bad decision you know
I'm gonna sort of hold off on answering
only because I don't know enough about
what's on the ground there my I'll tell
you what my instincts are my instincts
are to respect the other so-called
underground church that has lived in you
know dire circumstances often of a great
persecution but I want to be careful
because I really don't know what's on
the ground in detail I don't know what
was animating or motivating the Vatican
decision there my instincts are with the
the underground Church but I wouldn't to
say much more about it because I don't
claim to know enough about what's on the
ground so I discussed this with Pastor
John MacArthur what do you think are
these significant philosophical
differences put aside sort of the story
differences where we accept the first
half of the book and not the second half
between Judaism and Catholicism so aside
from Jesus and the acceptance of Jesus
where do you think they're real
significant philosophical
differentiation well that's a big aside
though I mean that's the heart of the
matter but let me say this first though
about Judaism and Catholicism it's I
think I feel really strongly about is
it's the re Judaizing
of Catholicism that is evangelical II so
important precisely when you divorce
Catholicism from Judaism you get these
distortions of Jesus so common today
Jesus as teacher of timeless spiritual
truths Jesus as guru Jesus as Gnostic
you know master Jesus is as Paul said
the yes to all the promises made to
Israel
Jesus is the climax to the story of
Israel therefore not to know Israel is
not to know Jesus not to know Torah and
covenant and temple and prophecy is not
to know Jesus the very fact I'll tell
you this interesting thing so when a
Protestant minister
comes out to preside at the liturgy
he'll wear either business suit or he'll
where is doctor robes because the heart
of the matter is is teaching right the
pulpit you're gonna teach it you're a
doctor or a teacher when I come out now
especially as a bishop who is a kind of
a high priest in the Catholic thing I
come out in the robes of a temple priest
including the mitre of a temple official
I use incense there's an altar a
sacrifice takes place the Catholic Mass
is unintelligible apart from from the
temple apart from Jewish worship and so
to reeju two eyes the operation is the
key to to evangelism because the good
news that that Paul has and Peter and
James and John it's not some some
Gnostic insight it's not some some
change of consciousness the good news is
you know the promises made Israel God
has said yes to all of them do you know
that the great story of Israel it's from
creation to the fall to the formation of
the people and Torah temple and prophecy
you know that great story it's reached
its fulfillment in Jesus that's why Paul
goes into the synagogue's first so he
comes into Corinth or he comes into
Athens or ever he goes his first move of
course is to the Jews because then
they'll get the story he's talking about
talking to Gentiles it's a far more
complicated business if you're an
evangelist because the story of Jesus
won't make sense apart from Judaism so
there I want to insist upon this deep
congruence and it does have
philosophical overtones the belief in
the one God here o Israel the Lord your
God has got alone that's that is of
enormous philosophical significance and
I would say it's one more is what's your
name you know Moses asking the Lord what
should I tell them I am Who I am
- reads that of course is the one in
whom essence and existence coincide that
God is is he's being asked to me which
which God are you there are a lot of
God's you know which which instance of
deity are you and then the great answer
that's the wrong question that's the
wrong way of thinking about the Creator
God of Israel I am Who I am my manner of
being is being itself not this
particular instance of being so that's
of enormous philosophical importance
coming up
out of Israel into the church and then
finally into its own philosophical
thinking but I want to redo two eyes
Catholicism because he's the thing is in
many parts the Protestant movement
there's that there's a desire to deegeu
two eyes the operation right that
there's we've overcome that and we've
kind of left that behind
Catholicism lifts it up it doesn't want
to leave it behind that's why the the
permanence of the Covenant made Israel
so important to us this coven has not
been been violated
God can't say no to the great covenant
he made it has permanent validity and
that's important for our theology for
our liturgy I was gonna ask you about
that because it for a long time
a dominant strain of Catholic thought
was a replacement theology the idea that
the Jews had sort of been left behind
that the new covenant had been made with
with the folks who followed the new
church where does that stand right now I
mean what does the Catholic Church think
of the idea that the Jews have sort of
been superseded yeah we're against
supersessionism we're in favor of it go
back to Paul's line that's the one
that's me that sums it up Christ is the
yes to all the problems as made to
Israel so you won't understand him apart
from Israel he's he's the fulfillment of
Israel we've been grafted on to the to
the branch of Israel you know all of
that
that's not supersessionism that's a it's
a fulfillment theology it's a
fulfillment of the covenant theology but
the covenant made to Israel remains a
valid covenant for that reason it's been
it's been brought to it is fruition you
know so that's why I'm not going to
simply reduce it and say well there's no
difference because I'm an evangelist I
mean I'm a Christian evangelist I want
everyone to know the good news they a
one Gallion about Jesus but it's Jesus
the Jew who's the Incarnation not of
just any old God he's the interrelation
of the God of Israel he's the God that
spoke to to Abraham Isaac and Jacob and
to Moses that's the one I'm talking
about and he became incarnate in in
Jesus so you can't make sense of apart
from Judaism so one of the things that
as an Orthodox Jew I often feel when I
speak to people who are either Catholic
or Protestant people who again believe
in the validity of the Old Testament but
also believe in the validity of the New
Testament is that one of the ways in
which differentiation is made is by
saying that certain things were lacking
in Judaism that are now present in
Christianity that had to be fulfilled by
Jesus that without Jesus these thing
could not have been fulfilled and I
guess that is the question that I'm
asking is where do you see those things
because very often I hear that you know
man is a sinful creature and that we
need you know we need Jesus in order to
take on our sins because otherwise we
couldn't live in the world basically or
that the or that Judaism is not
forgiving enough or not loving enough or
not in favor of atonement enough and I
think it's a Jew who prays three times a
day for atonement has a full day devoted
to atonement on Yom Kippur has a full
month before that devoted to atoning in
preparation for the atonement on Yom
Kippur you know with with all with all
of this stuff I get the feeling
sometimes as a Jew that one of the ways
the Christians differentiate from
Judaism is by miss casting the nature of
Judaism so that's why that's why I'm
asking for no specificity here I would
say is think all the institutions of
Israel Torah Temple Covenant prophecy
their purpose is to bring divinity and
humanity together I would say so
Zion the temple Yahweh's dwelling place
the tribes go up and they commune
through sacrifice you know with the Lord
it's the place of encounter the law is
meant to bring us into conformity with
the will of God Yahweh speaks his will
our wills are off-kilter but they come
together ideally through the Torah the
prophets God speaking as it were through
them and they're trying to draw us back
to tour and temple etc covenant you know
all of it is meant to bring them
together what's in the heart of
Christianity is that divinity and
humanity have met now perfectly in these
two natures Sam purposely kind of Greek
affine the language now but these but
that's it's all it's all Jewish talk
translated for Greeks at the time it's
all Jewish talk I want Yahweh and his
people Yahweh and Israel have now met in
such a perfect union that I can speak of
it as a hypostatic Union is a union of
person the hypostatic union of two
natures divine and human in one divine
person that's who Jesus is that's what I
mean when I say he's the fulfillment of
the temple the fulfillment of the Torah
the fulfillment of prophecy what they
what they want has happened now fully in
him that's why you know the great scene
of the Roman soldier pierced in the side
of the crucified Jesus out comes blood
water the blood of the Eucharist and
water baptism is one way to read it but
the other way is the fulfillment of
Ezekiel you know that at the time of the
renewal the temple when when the
Shekinah of Yahweh comes back what will
come forth from the side of the temple
but water life-giving water for the
renewal of the world and so these first
century Jews looking at mashiach ieshua
are saying look there it is in this
great act of sacrifice on the cross now
read in temple language divinity
humanity have met the atonements been
affected the covenants been fulfilled
you know and the sign of it is the
coming forth of water from the side of
the renewed temple now all of its
depended upon the resurrection if Jesus
Christ had died in the cross and stayed
his grave none of this would make a lick
of sense everything I'm saying it would
be a lot of hooey and and Christianity
would just be a waste of time what what
got it off the ground was the
resurrection of Jesus from the dead
which is what convinced these first
century Jews and I think you know of
like rabbi Showell
studying at the feet of Gamaliel who
knew everything I've been talking about
it a thousand things more when he met
the Risen Jesus that's what he got and
it took him a while and it goes off to
Arabia we hear a paul goes up into
arabia where'd he go I don't know no one
knows where he went but he went away
then he's in Tarsus from a number of
years what's he doing I think he's
trying piece it together he's trying to
piece it together how the promises made
to Israel have now been fulfilled in
this most unexpected way through a
crucified Messiah who's risen from the
dead but when he figured out he out he
comes to Corinth and then Philippi and
finally Rome to announce this new
Messiah you know so it's a it's a deeply
Jewish movement that makes sense only in
that context when you abstract from it
you you undermine its evangelical power
so I'm going to ask you in one second
one final question I want to ask you
specifically about Jordan Peterson and
biblical movements without the Bible per
se without the divinity of the mile per
se
but to hear the answer from Bishop Baron
you first must be a subscriber to
subscribe go to daily wire.com click
subscribe to watch the rest of the show
there Bishop Baron thanks so much for
coming it really has been a pleasure
I've really enjoyed thanks so much for
the time double-o soon the Ben Shapiro
shows Sunday special is produced by
Jonathan hey executive producer Jeremy
borin associate producer Mathis Glover
edited by Alex Singaram audio is mixed
by Dylan case hair and makeup is by Jess
wah
Oliveira and title graphics by Cynthia
and gula the Ben Shapiro shows Sunday
special is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018
[Music]
you